hey everybody i
am dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for march
31st the last day of march in the year
of 2021
and we have a tremendous show for you uh
before i do anything else don't forget
to subscribe
click that notification bell and i just
want to welcome you you know the show's
been doing really well we're getting
really good numbers new people are
coming every now and again i start the
show
by saying oh welcome conspiracy
theorists or nazis or things of that
nature
of course all of you are not those
things
that would be insane that would be
almost mathematically impossible
i know you're good people you're good
decent people who pick up the new york
times
in the morning and read it as gospel who
watch cnn
for true information who obey the
government
at all turns those are the type of good
citizens you are
you get pricked when they tell you to
get pricked you stay home when they tell
you to stay home
you wear a mask when they tell you to
wear a mask because you
are a good not only american because i
know we have an international audience
you're a good citizen of the world when
you're leaders
the people above you who are better than
you
when they tell you to do something you
do it and that's why
i'm happy to have you here at the reuben
report just kidding people that was all
nonsense
um you're independent thinkers that's
why i like you that's why i do the show
uh all right we got four stories for you
but a bonus fifth one which i'm gonna do
in under 30 seconds because this story
was just so idiotic i just saw this on
twitter and it's just such a
perfect perfect perfect perfect example
of how
dishonest the media is so a guy by the
name of eddie zipperer
who works over at townhall.com he
posted these two images side by side on
the twitter machine this morning
and he's talking about the new york
times coverage
of trump's 200 billion dollar bill
over 10 years an infrastructure bill
versus biden's two trillion
over eight year infrastructure plan okay
just to be very clear let me repeat that
but trump's plan was 200 billion dollars
over 10 years for infrastructure
bidens is 2 trillion trillions more than
billion
over eight years that's less years the
first one i'm going to read here the
first tweet this is what they said about
trump's when trump was trying to do it
coming up with the 200 billion in
federal funding will not be easy
republicans have already ballooned the
deficit in last week's spending
agreement and with their tax cuts
democrats are unlikely to go along with
cuts that would offset the cost of mr
trump's plan
okay so when it's a republican trying to
spend 200 billion over 10 years
that's tough that's tough that doesn't
sound like we can do it we probably can
do that we can't do that we don't have
the money for that
now their coverage of joe biden's
two trillion dollar plan in less time
but even spread over years the scale of
the proposal underscores how fully mr
biden has embraced
the opportunity to use federal spending
to address
long-standing social and economic
challenges
in a way not seen in half a century all
right
that's it that's it do i even have to
add anything else to this one
the new york times is not a newspaper if
you have a bird
i would not use the newspaper as the
place for the bird to poop
that's what you put at the bottom of a
bird cage i suppose find something
better it's not even worthy of your
parrot's poop
now before we get to the four oh i'll
tell you the four stories why don't i do
that
uh first off this video is going viral
aoc that clown
uh on instagram she just put up this
video about immigration and it's just
it's just endless drivel and i debated
whether even to do it because even
listening to her voice i start getting a
searing pain in my brain but all right
we're going to do that one for you
then this one i'm really interested in
and i think you guys are going to dig it
uh you know texas opened up about 18 19
days ago
uh and a guy by the name of drew holden
who i've given a shout out to on the
show once or twice before he does great
twitter threads really
if you're on twitter i don't recommend
anyone be on twitter but if you're on
twitter
the guy's worth a follow he did this
spectacular thread that we're going to
show you of all of the doomsdayers all
of the people that 18 days ago
including the president of the united
states the governor of this banana state
that i live in and many more
saying that texas was going to turn into
a zombie apocalypse and this was a
disaster and everything else meanwhile
texas numbers are just
completely flattening like they're
they're just their numbers are lowering
and lowering and lowering flattening to
the point of flat it's just going to be
gone and that'll be it
uh so i thought we'd call out all of the
people who got everything wrong i
thought that would be nice
then there's a really spectacular story
that you are absolutely not going to see
on cnn or new york times or anywhere
else but it's really really important a
professor in new jersey
a white professor in new jersey
is suing the university that he works at
because he was passed over
for a promotion because he got passover
for two guys who happened to be black
and he's got some evidence that would
say he should have got the promotion
and it's believed at least the lawsuit
alleges that this has something to do
with the color of
his skin some might call this reverse
racism i just call it racism we'll dive
into that and then finally
i almost killed someone last night um i
was
having a glass of wine i was actually
having a very nice night i had a very
fruitful day a lot of good things
happening
i was finishing up the day with a glass
of wine and i was sitting outside
clyde who is over here he was right by
me we were just having a nice night
and then i got an email from uh the city
of los angeles uh technically it was
from the city of west hollywood which is
where i used to live so i
i guess i'm still on some emails there
they put us in the orange tier and they
announced what the rules are and i
started reading the rules
and i almost choked the dog and now i
know peta is going to come after me but
i was i started to actually crack
because the rules are so ridiculous
and so arbitrary and so made up and all
we would have to do is stop paying
attention to these people and go about
living our lives and then that would be
it
they only have power over us because we
keep granting it to them anyway i'm
gonna read a whole bunch of these
nonsensical rules so four stories for
you i'm feeling good
i hope you are strapped in and before we
do anything else
i want to talk to you about ancestry.com
guys did your great-grandmother work
hard to raise her children and keep her
family together that's old school
did your family preserve persevere
through natural disasters
or and rebuild or start anew was there a
health care worker in your family's past
who cared for another generation facing
a pandemic
our ancestors were ordinary people who
lived through extraordinary situations
something we can all understand today
challenging times are nothing new and
neither are resilient people
learning about the struggles and
adversity your family went through can
bring you closer to your own family
today as you share your stories
and form new bonds ancestry helps you
search billions of records to learn more
about the ancestors who came through
remarkable challenges so you could be
here today
and this place is pretty good you can
find details about their lives see what
they did to earn a living and census
records
or see their actual signature on a
military record as they signed up to
fight for our country
learning their stories helps you find a
connection to what they went through and
how they stood strong through hardships
and struggles
when you get closer to your ancestors by
learning their stories you have a new
way
to get closer to your family there's
strength in every family story learn
more about yours at ancestry head to my
url at ancestry.comruben to start your
free trial that's ancestry.com
reuben and now back to me all right so
we've talked a little bit about kids in
cages we showed you
some video the other day ted cruz went
to the border facility and tried to
videotape these
jam packed absolutely jam-packed
somebody said they're at over a thousand
percent capacity
these cages that these children are in
and young people are in
they're basically packed like sardines
they're wearing that tin foil stuff to
stay warm
you know you can see people some have
masks some don't we're being told we
have to
socially distance but i guess if you
come to america
and just get into one of these rooms
somehow you don't have to social
distance half the time you don't have to
wear a mask they're probably giving you
them better food than
we're getting in half of the public
schools here well aoc who really
is the clown of all politicians i mean
the thing that you need to understand
about aoc is she first off she's an
actress
basically she's an actress and
somebody's just pulling her strings i
don't think she actually
believes well maybe she believes what
she's saying i don't want to impute her
motives in that way
but i think she's just sort of handed
information and then she can just
regurgitate it well
and i think they've really trained her
on how to speak and
when to move her arms and when to look
away from the camera and all of these
things and
and watch for those when we show you
this clip in just a second
but i tweeted this out this morning and
just put this in the back your head as
you're watching the clip
at any point in anything you're going to
see right now as she's talking about the
border crisis do you think there's any
concern for anyone that is an american
now
is there any concern for the
constitution of the united states or for
any of
the legal citizens or the people who
have come here legally
over the years or is she up to something
else that seems deeply anti-american so
just kind of put that in the back of
your head
and let's listen to aoc
are you for real well let's talk about
this because
so much of our national conversation
which is not a conversation
about immigration is driven by people
who could not care less about immigrants
often people want to say why are you
talking about the border crisis
or why aren't you talking about it in
this way well we're talking about it
they just don't like how we're talking
about it
because it's not a border crisis it's an
imperialism crisis it's a climate crisis
it's a trade crisis
and also it's a carceral crisis
because as i have already said
even during this term and this president
our immigration system is based and
designed on our carceral system
god she is just awful just the way she
speaks and it's not this
like it's just over emotive theater
with her it's not a border crisis it's
an imperialism
crisis really every country has a right
to defend its borders
as it sees fit now the reason she thinks
that she
that we don't have that right is because
she doesn't believe we should have that
right
because she does not believe that
america is a fundamentally good or
just place i don't think i'm really
giving much poetic license when i'm
saying that that seems
fairly obvious do any progressives seem
like they would stand
up for anything that would be thought of
as
americans say 10 years ago something
that 90 percent of us all would have
stood for who does she seem to care more
about the people that are here legally
or the people that are trying to come in
that's not to say we shouldn't let
anyone in we are a nation of immigrants
but it's an imperialism crisis it's a
climate crisis of course the same woman
who told us that the earth is going to
end in 12 years and unless we pass her
green new deal girl who's never
accomplished anything other than being a
bartender and i have no problem with
bartending i bartended when i was doing
stand-up back in the day
uh it's like oh if we just passed your
trillion dollar
made-up operation that you put on a lot
of paper then you'll save
the world yeah and it's a trade crisis
anyway
they are they are using overly emotive
ridiculous language and a character
actor
basically to trick young people and we
gotta i don't know what it is exactly
that those of us who care about this
country
um and by the way she says this thing
about we don't have a conversation about
immigration
i see conservatives and right-leaning
people having conversations
all the time show me someone i mean
there's virtually nobody that says we
should have no immigration there's
virtually nobody
there's always an honest somewhat honest
maybe not through all
the politicians but there's always an
interesting debate happening about
what do you do with the roughly 12
million people who are here illegally
already
do you give them a pathway to
citizenship do you put them at the back
of the line do you have to deport some
of them
what if some of them had kids here and
then those are anchor babies i mean
there's so many things to talk about so
many things that we could honestly
discuss
like just right this moment i'm trying
to bring up some of the important things
we also have a pandemic are we making
sure that these people that we're
keeping in cages right now that are
packed like sardines on top of each
other that they're not going to suddenly
burst
forth into texas and then the rates are
going to go crazy which by the way
and i don't mean this to be hyperbolic
aoc would love that
aoc would absolutely love if they let
everybody out in texas
and then texas had a massive outbreak of
covet of course she would love that
because politically it would be the
greatest thing for
oh see texas opened up texas opened up
racist texas open up it's racist
for some reason i'm not sure i'm sure
abbot's racist got it he's got to be
racist he doesn't agree with aoc
and now the numbers are spiking we're
going to get in a little bit to why
that's actually not the case anyway look
has she said a word
about the the kids in cages in in any
other portion of that video not that i
saw remember remember we played it
yesterday and we've played it before
when when trump had kids in cages which
was less
kids than they've got right now because
there actually is a crisis right now and
we know i mean there's so many videos of
it but the media just doesn't touch them
and you can only see them on instagram
and freaking pinterest
is pinterest still a thing what was
pinterest i don't even know what
pinterest was it seems like something
but i'm pretty sure trump shouldn't be
allowed on it
but the point is uh she really cared
when it was trump now that it's biden
not less and yeah i don't like aoc can
you tell all right
uh the media and biden lied about texas
yeah let's just do this story right now
uh so the covid numbers from texas which
opened up about 18 days ago
have precipitously dropped since then so
i mentioned
there's a guy by the name of drew holden
on twitter and he grabbed this is this
is
you know twitter's are basically a
cesspool and a nightmare of evil
and no one really should be on there you
should join us though at
report.locals.com a lot of good people
no bots no trolls
and we're actually having real
conversations however every now and
again
a gem comes through on twitter and i
thought that this twitter thread by drew
was an interesting one because we know
that the numbers are dropping right
we just know it and and i would don't
take my word for it and don't even
google it
do you know somebody in texas give them
a call they're not dead
everybody's okay it's getting better and
they're letting the economy
work again they're letting people live
their lives again they're letting people
be free again let
i hate the phrase letting people be free
people are free and it's the government
that gets in our way on the freedom
anyway drew put together this
spectacular
thread of headlines that uh twitter
people put out or people put out on
twitter
some of them are not just twitter people
so let's take a look i'll just read a
couple of them
i'm not going to read all of them
because there's just a ton there but
first off these
these two that you're seeing here msnbc
and cnn uh they're talking about how
when when it happened meaning a few days
after
uh texas opened up uh joe biden he
called it neanderthal thinking
after the cdc warned against complacency
in the face of emergency corona variants
on monday
and but biden we also played the video
please
please put your mask on do it for me
old joe i could die at any moment gavin
newsom my
governor in this ridiculous state of
california he called it
absolutely reckless when texas
lifted its mask mandate again the
numbers have dropped since then you're
an idiot gavin
then there's beto o'rourke who's done
nothing other than become a media
superstar
while running a failed senatorial and
presidential campaign
he called it a death warrant for texans
i mean this guy is an
absolute clown who should be ignored at
the highest
possible level um abbott is killing
the people of texas that's what he says
in a tweet right there
uh cnn again former representative
better o'rourke says texas governor
abbott
moved to lift the face mask mandate is a
death warrant okay so you got that one
and then you see another one
from uh msnbc there uh julian
castro said that workers shouldn't be
put at risk for abbott's desperate
political games
okay thanks julian um
and he also said governor abbott has
ignored public health experts in
reopening texas and ending the mask
mandate
for your neighbors family friends please
keep wearing a mask in social distancing
yeah you were wrong again julian then
there's another one from nightly news
you see that one
experts warn this is nbc experts warn of
a perfect storm as states reopen and
covet variance spread
yeah it's not happening you are trying
to keep us all hysterical and afraid of
our own shadows
and it ain't working anymore let's keep
going uh cnn what's behind texas
governor's neanderthal thinking
what's behind it he wants people to be
able to live their lives
don't mess with texas it's crazy right
cnn
uh even as health officials warn not to
ease them
abbott did it bad man abbott uh here's
another one
i don't know who this woman is but she's
a blue czech person and if you're a blue
check person that means you're an
important
vital member of society the amount of
anxiety i'm hearing from folks in texas
is high
one friend told me i'm not going inside
stores if masks aren't enforced
i can't comprehend how abbott approached
this with such enthusiasm
it could backfire economically too my
god a blue check woman has a friend
who's upset about something jesus christ
out front on cnn brought dr jonathan
reiner on he's a former white house
medical advisor
he called abbott's decision to lift the
mask mandate and allow public businesses
to open 100 a gigantic mistake
we've seen this movie and it doesn't
turn out well
which movie okay oh and then i got to do
this one i got it
here you know what i want to reset for
this one do it proper
you know there's a lot of people out
there on the internet that spread nasty
rumors
okay one of the nastiest rumors one of
the most
deeply offensive hurtful rumors is that
i
dave rubin r-u-b-i-n am somehow related
to jennifer rubin who is a journalist or
columnist or analyst i believe at the
washington post
which is a place of journalism or
something like that
well jennifer rubin who is she used to
be a conservative like if you're
she's one of these people it's like you
know you know the line like if you don't
if you're not a liberal in your 20s you
don't have a heart and if you're not a
conservative in your 30s you don't have
a brain i think that's sort of like the
rough estimate
meaning that as you get older you should
become a little more conservative
because you want to conserve some of the
things that you now realize are good
from the past so i'm always very leery
when people evolve backwards and we do
get some versions of this
jennifer rubin this guy max boot there's
some
guy people that are seemingly like they
get it and then they lose it
i'm not even going to go into the
motives of why it happens anyway
i just want to be very clear that i am
in no way related
to jennifer rubin if we clip this
piece right now i hope that you will
share this on all of your social media
channels i'm dave rubin i'm in no way
related
to jennifer rubin my family does a
get-together
an extended cousins club kind of thing
every year she's never been there
she's never been invited we are not
related
and i want nothing to do with her her
tweet on this
jennifer rubin texas ranks a miserable
45th in terms of percentage of the
population
that has been vaccinated that means many
vulnerable
people will have to survive a state
where masks and other social distancing
restrictions
are widely ignored jennifer jennifer
i know we're not related so maybe i
don't have a right to say this to you
but your parents are not happy with you
nobody's happy with you
i mean jesus [ __ ] um opinion in the
washington post which i believe is where
jennifer works
why are we bailing out texas's reckless
decisions on covet 19
washington post which is just a crap
factory and then the daily show
which nobody watches the daily show
anymore trevinor
is not trevor noah i think that's the
name he's not funny
there's nothing interesting it's like
every now and again i see a clip come
across twitter and it's just
awful and depressing and harping and all
that stuff
um and nobody watches it right but we're
not really allowed to say it right we
can't really say it
you might be able to figure out why you
can't say it and why the show sucks
uh even as vaccines roll out it's
important to mask up keep our distance
and not do whatever texas is doing
well sorry trevor noah the facts the
numbers we showed them yesterday
prove that texas is doing just fine
and the point is that even if even if in
a few weeks from now
texas has a little spike or the numbers
go up a little bit
that would not prove anything other than
when there are viruses out there people
get sick but if you think the government
should be allowed to keep you in your
house forever at this point a year later
if you think they should be able to
dictate every decision that you make and
what you wear on your head and how
close you should get to your family and
friends and all those things you have a
severe psychological problem
and we should be maybe funding more
mental health although the idea that the
government would fund mental health i
see this around l.a a lot
there's a lot of new things like the la
department of health wants to help you
are you upset are you depressed call
them and it's like is there one person
in all of los angeles who called the la
department of health and is now mentally
healthier
like that person cannot possibly exist
in this cesspool of insanity first off
everyone hears on prescription drugs
anyway
i'm not but most people are that's why i
talk to you guys so
you know all right let's move on uh this
story is really interesting it's gonna
go super under-reported because it
doesn't fit the narrative but i think
there's really
something here and it's worth noting so
a white professor
is suing a new jersey college for racial
discrimination after finding out that
two of his black colleagues
earned 45 000 more than him
despite some similar qualifications and
experience so we've got some quotes here
from the daily mail this is this is
super interesting
so william lavelle he's 66 years old he
filed his lawsuit against camden college
on friday
after reportedly discovering the pay gap
under the state's public records law
in his lawsuit he argues that despite
similar qualifications and experience
black professors melvin roberts and
lawrence chapman
earn more than him his salary lavelle's
in 2021
is 91 000 roberts is 137
000 and chapman's is 142 000 that's a
pretty significant difference
lavelle has taught at the college for 26
years
roberts has more than 31 years
experience there and chapman has 30
years according to online records
the suit also argues that lavelle even
has more
professional degrees in his field of
concentration than the other two
professors named
he's seeking more than a hundred fifty
thousand dollars in damages
according to the lawsuit so look
i'm just reading off what daily mail is
reporting on this lawsuit
there could be some other things going
on there like it's very possible
a lot of his students don't like him
maybe he did some other things or got
into fights with other people
in the department like there could be a
litany of other reasons that this guy
did not get a promotion or that these
guys did that that pay gap there for
people with similar qualifications
and similar histories seems pretty
significant right it's basically a third
more that they're being
that they're being paid um but without
getting into all the nitty-gritty and
obviously as the lawsuit unfurls we'll
keep talking about it and we'll find out
more probably
but the specific point on this is that
we know
that if the script was flipped here
right so if
a black professor wasn't getting you
know
the the bonuses if he wasn't moving
forward
uh in a way that was commensurate with
his
white colleagues we know this would be
front page of new york times systemic
racism
colleges are racist the president would
have to step down it would end up being
like an evergreen
uh situation all over again and the rest
of it so i just thought
this was interesting i'm just sort of
putting this one here as a marker
of like i do sense we are going to see
more than this because what
is at the end of social justice like
what is at the end of critical race
theory well at the
end is a situation where every single
time
if you had two people and they had the
exact same qualifications and the exact
same resumes and one was white and one
was black you would always
choose the black person and that is
discrimination that is a problem so the
anti-racists as i always say are the new
racists
so again that's not to defend every
little thing in this lawsuit we might
find out some things
maybe he's not a great professor who
knows but i think it's worth mentioning
because i also think and i've said this
for a while too
that i think the one thing that
potentially can save us from this really
horrific onslaught that that is just
happening across the board
all over society right now is legal
measures i think that may be the last
chance that we've got that we've got to
challenge some of this stuff in court
that that equity that that laws
that promote equity are actually
anti-constitutional
right you cannot treat people as groups
you have to treat them as individuals
this is
it's like in many ways it's the most
fundamental american thing it's the most
it's most fundamental well jordan
peterson used to say something like this
on tour actually
he would say that the individual is the
most fundamental building block
in all of western thought it starts
there and they're trying to make it
start up there with the collective
it's seriously dangerous stuff okay
let's move on one more
you know it's another beautiful day here
in socal it's probably
78 and sunny i'm going to try to take as
many meetings as i can outside today
so are our benevolent leaders gavin
newsom
and the others eric garcetti is our
mayor here they've decided to put us in
the orange tier
and yesterday i was drinking a glass of
wine sitting outside with clyde and i
got the email
i got the email from the west hollywood
chamber of commerce
and it said the following los angeles
county has met the threshold
for the less restrictive orange tier in
the state's blueprint for a safer
economy
today the state released updated numbers
la county's adjusted case rate dropped
from 3.7 new cases
per 100 000 people to 3.1
new cases per 100 000 people
a revised los angeles county health
officer order will go into effect
on monday april 5th at 1201 am to
reflect
newly permitted activities okay all
right so we
things really didn't move that much you
could read it yourself
but now look what they're gonna let us
do this is from abc7
malls can open indoors with limited food
court capacity
so you can go and get a hot dog perhaps
but no no poke can't have poke too many
vegetables
can't have poke museums zoos and
aquariums
can open indoors at 50 capacity
i've been saying from the beginning i
don't understand how museums zoos and
aquariums are all in the same category
even
zoos are 90 outdoors and we've had our
zoo's close like
wouldn't zoos giant outdoor places where
people could wander around wouldn't have
that
wouldn't that have been good to have
kept open over the last year
but they can open up indoors at 50
capacity i don't know what that means
for the outdoor
capacity congratulations people who
believe in god
you old school people you can now pray
again at 50 capacity because
obviously if a church or
uh synagogue was to have 51 capacity
everybody would be dead there's no
science behind any of this it's all made
up
movie theaters i don't know that people
go to are ever going to go to the movies
again
and by the way when it comes to movies
you know one thing i've always been very
against you know i'm a big freedom guy
what do i say
i'm a radical freedom extremist but one
thing i've always been completely
against and i'll never waver on this
is remember back in the day when you
could go to the movie theater and then
suddenly they started allowing us to put
our own butter on the popcorn
and you could just go up they'd give you
the bucket you could then go up to the
machine and pump that thing and
on it it would say that the chemicals in
here cause cause alzheimer's truly you
would say it on there
and they would let you just endlessly
pump it people should not be allowed to
pump their own should be left to the
professionals
who were paid minimum wage behind the
counter anyway movie theaters
can open at 50 capacity or 200 people
whichever is fewer i mean again that
makes no
sense whatsoever it should be up to the
people who run the movie theater to
figure out
how it actually works and what they're
going to do and logistically how it
makes sense
hotels can open with modifications plus
their
indoor pools can open and fitness
centers can open at 25
capacity of course 80 percent of the
people who died of covid
were obese but we're gonna slightly
allow some people maybe to kinda every
now and again go to the gym that's nice
and speaking of gems gyms
can open indoors at 25 capacity and can
open
indoor pools what kind of gym i want you
all to think of your own gym right now
what kind of gym can survive at 25
capacity they are
trying to destroy everything and and
these these
peons these people that read this they
go oh my god i can go to the gym
25 capacity and i can go to the movie
theater at fifty percent maybe then i'll
pray and
it's like no then they'll just take it
away they're
they're giving you crumbs and then
they're gonna take away the crumbs don't
you get it already
restaurants can open indoors at 50
capacity do you know how hard it is
to open a successful restaurant
something like 90 of restaurants
fail within the first year in good times
it is so hard
to open a good restaurant there's so
many costs involved
and meat and cheese and veggies that
don't last forever and the turnover is
high and you have to really impress
people real quick or they there's so
many options
they won't come back well now they can
be open at 50
michael can you go down on that a little
bit uh they can open at 50
capacity or at 200 people whichever is
fewer again that's complete
that's complete arbitrary nonsense it
would depend on what the structure of
the building looked like and how high
the ceiling was and
do they have open windows and all those
things oh and i love this one wineries
breweries and distilleries
can open indoors at 25 or 100 people
whichever is fewer i think i've made my
point on the whichever is fewer thing
bars uh outdoor only so you still can't
go to a bar
you can't just sit at a bar and why is
that dangerous
you know there used to be a time when
people
you might go oh you know i'm going to go
out for a drink maybe i'm going to say
hello to a stranger and you know where
you would do that you would do that at a
bar
okay did you ever see a show called
cheers with ted danson great show
long time ago people used to hang out
where everyone knew their name it was a
bar it was called cheers you might have
a bar in your hometown
the ability for them to take away all of
the things that tie us together and just
keep us home
keep us online keep us fat keep telling
us we're racist
bad combo people uh so bars are outdoor
only
family rest entertainment centers are
open
indoors at 25 capacity for naturally
distant
activities like bowling and rock
climbing so
i you can go bowling at 25 capacity i
guess that's not terrible because one of
the worst things in life we've you know
you want to talk about true oppression
everyone's always talking about
depression
when you're about to bowl you know you
got your arm cocked back you're
about to throw it down the lane and then
somebody runs up and they're gonna bowl
right at the same time and
you gotta have respect if i'm bowling in
my lane you gotta wait until i throw
that ball then you come in so 25
i guess technically you could do it at
50 to get it right that way because then
you could just skip every other one
but i would say in this case in bowling
it's okay i think you see how stupid
this is
card rooms because that's an important
one that they should be regulating
there's a lot of card rooms all over la
open indoors at 25 capacity
non-essential offices encourage telework
but you can reopen
in-person workspaces professional sports
outdoor stadiums
can have audiences of up to 33 capacity
schools can reopen for in-person
instruction after five days out of the
purple tier
theme parks can reopen at 25 capacity
but don't forget we did a story a week
or two ago
that if you yell while on a roller
coaster they can kick you out of the
theme park i mean
they're gonna have to put snipers
they're gonna have to put snipers at the
top of the jurassic park log flume
uh and then live is outdoor only at 33
capacity this is totally unrelated but
once i went to oc
to see journey orange county oc orange
county i went to see journey
about 10 years ago i was with kelly
carlin my friend kelly carlin who's been
on the show george carlin's daughter
great gal and david the three of us
and we got busted at an outdoor journey
concert for smoking a joint
i thought you legally had to smoke a
joint at an outdoor journey concert in
oc but we got busted
we got busted i don't know where the
covid you know regulations stand on
smoke and weed outdoor
journey concert i'll have to call my
local authorities uh guys
uh part two of my interview with
janisteen which is she's just
spectacular i hope you watch part one
already or watch
the full at locals.com
she's just wonderful she's fighting
andrew cuomo and
what do i always say i like people who
do not just talk and she's actually
putting
some pretty pretty tragic moments of her
life losing her in-laws during covid
because they were in the
old age homes when they sent all those
people back
well she's now fighting andrew cuomo
tooth and now it's a pretty beautiful
story and she took some pain and turned
into something good so part two is up on
youtube right now
full is up as always ad free at
report.locals.com oh
and on this friday uh we're going to be
doing a panel
with bishop baron and rabbi wolpe so i
thought you know because we're
well passover was a few days ago
technically it's still going but the
seders were a few days ago and of course
easter is this sunday i thought it'd be
interesting to talk
to a bishop and a rabbi we'll talk about
the season the importance of these
stories and the messages
and belief and all that good stuff so
tune in for that and i think tomorrow
we'll do a q a q a tomorrow what do you
say all right q a tomorrow so if you
want to submit questions
for the q a i only take questions
submitted at reubenreport.locals.com so
you got
about 23 hours to get yours in all right
guys have a great day
and if you go bowling make sure you're
at a 25
capacity bowling alley and they're not
letting you
butter up your own popcorn have a good
one